the nicest gift i've ever got from from
a fan was uh
it was also ax
no so someone someone had uh given me
also like a it was like a handwritten
letter but with
letter was like it came in a box and in
the box was like
a lot of origami cranes that she was
like cool that she had like
folded herself and i'm like did you do
this all by hand she's like yeah you
know i was just bored and i just wanted
to give you something that was memorable
and it was definitely memorable because
it was like i you know i was like i mean
telling the story of it right now yeah
exactly i still remember to this day i
still have it
i [ __ ] it was the first time i felt
like maybe i'm doing some good in this
world man
i'm so happy thank you so much but yeah
it was talking about anime titties
have you seen like that vine or whatever
where the guy's making a sandwich with
crisps it's like you made this for me
bro you made it for me i love you bro
that's how i felt in that exact moment
do you remember that like really like
creepy statue i had at my house
yeah i loved this i loved it a fan had
made me the statue yeah
and it was like a proper clay statue
right and it was like
you know i don't think they were like
amazing at it but it was so [ __ ]
sweet but it was so cursed and creepy at
the same time
but it was such so so i just couldn't
imagine the amount of thought they put
into this that i was like i [ __ ]
loved it so much so i
kept it in my house so whenever people
came to my house they're like the [ __ ]
is that
what is that and i'm like oh it's a
statue of me like you
that's you i'm like it's not the most
flattering but a fan gave it to me like
oh that's nice yeah yeah yeah
probably because when you said the
statue of views like did you make that
the thing was as well is that it kind of
really beat up because uh it like it
went through the mail as well yeah and
i had to like i i thought this thing was
so cool they'd done it that i spent like
an hour and a half
super gluing it all back together just
so i could
display it in my house and creep
everyone out i guess by accident but i
thought like oh this is so sweet and
that's in my parents house scooping them
up
thank you that one fan who sent me that
statue of me in like an al pose yeah we
we appreciate that [ __ ] so much honestly
yeah yeah
we don't do anything that amazing to be
able to get gifts
like given being given anything it just
feels really
weird that i'm glad you would you know
want to give something to us anyway yeah
exactly and not weird in a bad way just
weird for us because we're just like we
don't do anything special we're just
[ __ ] talking [ __ ] make videos
talk about anime titties and whatever
it's very humbling because i i again i
i i feel like i make the videos just to
for myself and you know to pay the bills
yeah it's kind of like the main reasons
you know what that like i make the
videos first and foremost for me
and then it's just like i constantly
forget how much
people enjoy them and it's really just
like oh [ __ ]
these mean things to people like i don't
know not that my videos are like worth
meaning anything i don't think that i'm
not conceited at all to think that but
when people are like oh yeah my videos
are deep right like you mean to you she
was like you know i'm doing this
because it keeps people happy i'm
changing without me depression would go
up ten percent
i'm changing the wall i'm like you might
react yeah